- This tastes great.
I'm sorry, what?
(upbeat, fun instrumental music)
- [Voiceover] Gourmet fry
sauce, premium dipping sauce.
- Fries don't need sauce, necessarily.
- Is it like burger sauce?
- Ooh, that is really good.
- I love the catchphrase, which is,
"Fries want it, ketchup wants to be it."
- There's gotta be a lot
of mayonnaise in here.
- It's a little decadent.
- And there is.
- It's burger sauce.
- Tastes like cake.
- This is honestly like
my favorite sauce ever.
I would put this on everything.
- [Voiceover] Reindeer hot dog?
- This is reindeer?
- No way, is it, wait, no, what?
- No.
- I'm so excited to eat
this, is that freaky?
- Let's see how it tastes.
- Tastes like a hot dog, but gourmet.
- It's pretty good.
- This is phenomenal.
- It's a bit more meaty.
- Let's kill more
reindeer, it's delicious.
- I would eat that with fry sauce.
- This is a gamey hot dog.
Reindeer is game meat, I'm game.
- [Voiceover] The Elvis
sandwich, this is very exciting.
- I really love, like, banana
and peanut butter, and bacon,
but the thought of them
together is a little strange.
- Here's to you, baby.
- Oh my God, that's amazing.
- I don't like it.
- That's the most confusing
mouthful I've ever had.
- All right, I get it.
- The texture of a banana and bacon
should never be together.
- What a way to go.
In fact, I guess this is the
sandwich you wanna die on.
- [Voiceover] Courgar Gold, rrahrh.
- Washington State University.
- Canned cheese, does it go back?
- You show up to my house with this,
I mean, yeah, you can come in,
but I have a lot of
questions, who are you?
- That's a fine cheese.
- What is going on?
My taste buds are like, hurting right now.
- I can see being drunk
at 3 AM and comin' home
and just ripping this thing open.
- Okay, you show up to my house with this,
we can hang out.
- This is really similar to,
like, British strong cheddar.
Yes, this is what you need
in this country more often.
- Cougar Gold, you are golden.
- All right, and dessert.
- Have I heard of pigs feet, yeah.
That's the thing that you say I won't eat
unless you do this.
- Oh my God, I wish you could
smell through the camera.
- All right.
- I feel really bad for
anyone that likes this food,
I'm sorry, I don't mean
to be an asshole about it.
- Nice to meet you, bro, nice to meet you.
- Oh, no.
- I can say no, right.
(upbeat, fun instrumental music)
- Hun-uh, hun-uh.
- Oh, it's pickled?
- And now it's kinda gelatinous
and a little bit gross.
Like, here's the inside view.
- Oh my God, nope.
- I mean, I can see, like,
maybe it's an acquired taste.
- I'm actually really curious to find
someone that likes that,
'cause I want to talk to them about it.
- Listen, what you just
did was inappropriate.
Um, you've crossed a line.
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh, yeah, mm-hmm.
You don't know the half of it.